SIERRA: How does a war … end?
When the conflict in Ukraine first started,
a lot of people predicted that Russia would
win.
But that hasn’t happened.
In fact the Ukrainian army, backed by the
West, has succeeded in holding off Russian
forces and even reclaiming territory.
But as Putin faces losses on the battlefield,
he appears to be growing more volatile.
Things have not stopped escalating.
And this got me thinking, how can a war like
this …end?
How does any war end?
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, we turn once again to our very own
Richard Haass, to ask some big questions about
war, compromise, and all the shades of gray
involved in negotiating peace.
The following interview is largely uncut.
Gabrielle SIERRA: All right.
Richard Haass, welcome back.
Richard HAASS: Always good to be with you,
Gabby.
SIERRA: Season six of Why It Matters and you've
stopped by for your what's-up-in-the-world
update.
Unfortunately, we are still discussing the
war in Ukraine.
I just sort of want to start by saying that
it seems like Putin's not doing as well as
he thought he would, we all thought he would,
which is a good thing in theory, but it seems
to be that it's becoming more and more volatile
as defeats pile up and it's kind of getting
scary even though he is losing.
So just this morning, he launched a large-scale
missile attack that struck at least 10 cities
in Ukraine.
So, is it good he's losing?
Is it bad?
Is he losing?
HAASS: There's 10 questions in there-
SIERRA: You're welcome.
HAASS: Let me say a few things.
The trends in the war on the battlefield are
against Russia, that is true.
Ukraine knows why it's fighting more.
Its troops are better trained, they're better
motivated, seem to be better armed, certainly
better led.
Every day that goes by, it looks like Ukraine
is regaining control of a bit of territory,
but they've got a long, long, long ways to
go and it's always or normally, it is more
difficult to take territory than it is to
hold territory.
It's more demanding to be on the offensive
than the defensive.
So even though the trends are going against
Russia on the battlefield, it could be a very
long playing out.
There's nothing that's necessarily imminent.
And just because we saw some pockets of collapse
in the Northeast, I don't believe it would
be right to generalize and say that the Russian
Army writ large is about to collapse.
Point one.
What I think we're seeing though from Mr.
Putin is what I would term or dub an indirect
strategy.
He can't prevail on the battlefield against
Ukraine.
So what he is trying to do is essentially
extend the battlefield, literally and figuratively.
By that I mean with Ukraine, which had gotten
used to the idea that the war is something
that takes place on a front, but not in downtown
Kyiv.
And indeed, when I was in Kyiv pretty recently,
a few weeks ago, it felt like any other European
capital.
People were sitting around drinking coffee
in the cafes and going out for dinner and
strolling and so forth.
These recent renewed missile attacks against
civilian targets are psychologically tough.
Not just physically tough, given the casualties,
but psychologically tough.
Plus they will likely make it more difficult
for Ukraine to economically rebuild.
It adds a tremendous degree of risk.
You can never be sure when there might not
be another attack.
One thing that Putin is doing is taking the
war again to Ukrainian cities.
Secondly, he's taking the war to Europe and
his principal weapon is natural gas, and what
he's hoping is that in a long cold winter,
the Europeans will come to regret their support
economically and militarily for Ukraine.
And then thirdly, by his nuclear threats,
he's hoping he can get the United States to
think twice.
He wants to hear more and more voices in the
United States saying, "This game isn't worth
the candle.
Yes, we care about Ukraine.
Yes, we care that territory is not acquired
by force."
But Putin is hoping that a lot of people say,
"Is this really worth a nuclear exchange?"
And what Putin is obviously hoping is Americans
decide not.
So that's his strategy.
We'll see how it plays out.
I don't think, at the moment, he will succeed
in that, if I were a betting man, which of
course I’m not.
But if I were a betting man, though I am sorry,
I did not bet on the Giants recently.
But if I were a betting man, I would think
this war continues.
SIERRA: I mean to bridge off of that, people
seem to be talking a lot more about nuclear
weapons, which honestly is kind of a first
for me in my life.
How scared should I be?
And also, if a nuke is used there on the battlefield,
would it affect us?
HAASS: Look, Russia could use at least in
imagination or a principle, small nuclear
weapons sometimes called tactical nuclear
weapons.
They could be used on a battlefield or they
could be used in some demonstration area over
the ocean.
It would be a way of backing or further reinforcing
these threats.
If you use them over a battlefield, it could
have an immediate effect.
There would be some radioactive particles
and all that.
The wind could blow it in any number of directions.
It wouldn't affect us, but it could affect
other parts of Ukraine, other parts of Europe,
other parts of Russia.
Again, my own view is that Putin is more likely
to be threatening these than actually using
these.
I understand the logic of the threat more
than I understand the logic of use, though
I could see the logic of a demonstration test,
not in a populated area.
And one of the things we are doing, by we
I mean the United States government, to the
best of my knowledge, is communicating to
him with some degree of specificity why he
would regret any use of nuclear weapons.
There's various ideas that have been bandied
about.
I've talked about removing the constraint
on the use of American air power over Ukraine.
Others have talked about, I think it was General
Petraeus, about taking out the Russian Black
Sea Fleet.
But the idea would be, we have fought this
war indirectly through arming Ukraine and
if Russia crossed the threshold, we could
end that self-imposed restraint and we could
say, "The Russian forces in Ukraine would
be decimated."
Now, the danger there is obviously if we were
to do that, does that contribute to escalation?
SIERRA: Right.
HAASS: I can't sit here and tell you there's
no chance it wouldn't.
That is always though the case, and that was
the case in 1962 during the Cuban missile
crisis and so forth.
And the only thing that is particularly worrisome
now is that this leadership of Russia, Vladimir
Putin, operates we think with fewer constraints
than his predecessors did, what 60 years ago,
which is quite a remarkable statement.
But again, we've got multiple norms here and
we don't want the threat of nuclear use to
totally immobilize us because that will simply
encourage further threats of nuclear use by
Russia or others.
We don't want to put sweeteners on the table
so Ukraine or anybody would say, "Wow, you
guys are only offering this up because you
want to avoid a nuclear exchange," that teaches
a terrible lesson, and if that were the case,
they would be right.
So Putin has actually made it more difficult
for diplomats to do their work because there's
the danger now that it would look like a reward
for his threats, which is not something we
want to be doing.
SIERRA: So I guess my bigger question is,
how do wars end?
Like I actually don't know.
And from what you're saying, it's not very
simple.
It's not like packing up and going home.
How does this end?
HAASS: Look, wars can end in multiple ways.
One is that one side prevails over the other.
Originally, it looked like Russia might do
it over Ukraine.
That seems out of the question now.
Could one imagine it going the other way where
Ukraine routes the Russian forces?
Maybe, but we're not there.
The more likely scenario is neither side can
totally dominate the other.
The costs of continuing are judged to be high
by both sides, the human economic military
cost.
And that creates at least the possibility
of a negotiation.
This is something I've done as a diplomat,
not as successfully as I would like.
I've written about it as well.
But negotiations only succeed when you have
leaders who are willing and able to cut a
deal.
Willing is a question of disposition.
Able is a question of political strength.
Now Mr. Putin clearly has the political strength
to cut a deal, though I expect he worries
that if he were to cut a deal that looked
overly generous towards Ukraine, he could
face a real challenge from the right.
I think he's more worried about a challenge
from the right than he is from anywhere else.
But because of that, I'm not sure he's willing.
He also worries about any sign of weakness.
Indeed, the whole war was fought, I think,
less because of territory or Ukraine joining
NATO or anything like that.
I believe Vladimir Putin saw the example of
Ukraine.
This liberal, Slavic, tied to Europe country
on Russia's border, as an example that posed
an existential threat to Russia and therefore,
he wanted to pose an existential threat to
Ukraine.
For Volodymyr Zelensky to compromise right
now would be hard.
Ukrainians are not disposed to compromise.
I came away from my time there and I was there
just when the military trends were shifting
in Ukraine's directions.
The combination of the war itself, the atrocities
at Bucha, Izium, and elsewhere and then the
military progress, there weren't a lot of
doves left in Ukraine.
Indeed, the prevailing view is not only that
Ukraine wants to recover all of its territory
that it had in 1991, but also that it wants
economic reparations to pay for the cost of
the war and wants accountability for war crimes.
So you have a situation where right now, I
think, there's precious little that's diplomatic
talk for no overlap between what Ukraine and
Russia could compromise on.
Now, could that change at some point?
Yes, and I can think of all sorts of formulas.
Lots and lots of things but the bottom line
is at the moment, what usually prevents agreements
from happening from wars from formerly ending
is less the lack of imagination about a deal
than it is again the willingness and ability
of the respective leaderships to sign onto
one.
They have to believe they are better off with
a deal or worse off without a deal.
And at the moment, I don't think that's the
case.
I actually think both of them prefer an open-ended
war right now because that way, they don't
have to put their name on the dotted line
of any compromise.
SIERRA: Right.
I mean, do you think that the US is going
to stay involved and interested in the war?
I mean, you don't look forward to something
that drags on for years and years, which we're
familiar with.
HAASS: Well, one of Vladimir Putin's hopes
is that the answer to your question is not,
that either after the midterm elections here,
there could be a changed political landscape
in the United States.
Simply Americans have sometimes a collective
case of ADD.
There might be other international situations,
more likely domestic situations, that absorb
a lot of our energies, that, plus Europeans
might, during a cold winter, basically say,
"The costs of supporting Ukraine alienating
Russia aren't worth it."
Ukraine itself, Putin's hoping gets somewhat
demoralized by the renewal of shelling of
civilians.
So Putin is hoping that time does for him
what his army has not.
SIERRA: Have there been situations like this
before where we had to provide someone with
an offramp or had to really balance between
giving someone some concessions while also
not, I don't know, negotiating with terrorists
type thing?
HAASS: Let's take the historical parallels
in two ways.
One is, could you have a somewhat open-ended
war?
Well, history is filled with wars that go
on a long time.
And even now, the situation between North
Korea and South Korea, there's not formal
peace; there's an armistice, and it's more
the absence of war than anything remotely
looking like peace.
In lots of situations, you have open-ended
conflicts that may flare up Israel and Palestinians,
Israel and Hamas.
And what happens is you have certain signaling,
ground rules almost about how you conduct
it.
And every once in a while, one or the other
sides breaks one of those understandings or
ground rules, pursue some option.
There's a flare up, there may or may not be
some diplomatic contacts and then things get
tamped down again.
A lot of the Middle East, parts of Asia, have
that kind of, neither peace nor war.
Right now, we clearly have war between Russia
and Ukraine, but we could have something that's
not as intense.
I think again, there's a lot of precedent
for that.
The idea of offramps, which is an unfortunate
expression, but look, every negotiation, unless
it's unconditional surrender, and even those
have something in it for the other side.
So any agreement, by definition, usually has
concessions.
Either it's necessary to forge the agreement
or it's judged as desirable for what you want
to do afterwards, what your post-war goals
are.
Because very quickly, your goals post-war
might be different than your goals during
the war.
That happened in Europe and Asia after World
War II because suddenly the Cold War became
the context in which a lot of diplomacy was
carried out.
So, there's always things that are thrown
in.
I've been involved in negotiations in the
Middle East, India and Pakistan.
I was the US envoy to the Cyprus crisis for
years.
I was the US envoy in Northern Ireland.
And in all of those, you think of compromises.
In any negotiation, people have to be willing
and able, as I said, to agree.
Well, able, the ability of people to sign
a deal sometimes depends upon, you're giving
them something they can go back to their own
constituency and say, "Hey, I didn't get everything
but I got this and I got this critical feature."
So you have to decide if you value or sincerely
want an agreement, it's preferable to you
than not having one.
So the idea that you structure peace agreements
in that way in order to calm a situation and
provide the various parties with what they
need to enter into it, that's what the diplomacy's
all about,
SIERRA: Right.
But we're saying Russia, we're saying administrations,
but it's really Putin.
So how can I possibly feel safe in a modern
world where one dude can hold all this power
and decide whether or not he wants to say
yes to this?
It's one person.
HAASS: Well, there's many people in Ukraine
who would agree with you.
When I had conversations there, there were
literally members of the government who said,
"Why in the world would I want to sign an
agreement with this guy?" Or to use your technical
word, dude, as Jeff Bridges might put it,
given that it wouldn't be worth the paper
it's written on.
There are clearly a lot of people in Ukraine
who think that, and my bet is, there's more
people who think it now than did a couple
of weeks ago because of atrocities in Izium
or the recent shelling of cities.
That's a legitimate concern.
When Henry Kissinger spoke here at the council
recently, he warned against over personalizing
this and he said, "Just deal with Russia,"
essentially.
SIERRA: Interesting.
HAASS: Because we can't control whether Vladimir
Putin or somebody else is there.
So if you're worried about cutting a deal
with Vladimir Putin, and you should be, then
the question is, how do you construct it in
such a way that you build incentives for his
not breaking it and you build penalties in
if he were to.
I would think that entering into an agreement
with Vladimir Putin would have to take into
account that trust of him is, shall we say,
negligible.
His track record speaks for itself.
HAASS: It's hard for me to imagine any agreement
with Vladimir Putin and Ukraine.
But if one were to happen, it couldn't be
one, shall we say, that was faith-based, that
is out of the question.
SIERRA: And you think that this conflict could
keep going post Putin?
HAASS: Well, that depends upon what would
a successor government look like.
Look, every time a war ends, particularly
when it ends poorly, you will have those on
the center left in Russia who say, "This was
a war that never should have been started."
You will have those on the right who will
say, "The problem was not that Putin started
the war, it's how he and the generals fought
it."
And if you're of the latter school, if you
think the problem was how the war was prosecuted,
then the emphasis I think would be on improving
Russia's military.
You don't want to normalize with Ukraine.
With that kind of a successor leadership,
I don't see Russia becoming, needless to say,
reintegrated with Europe, at peace with Ukraine.
Now, I can imagine whether it's immediately
after Putin or maybe one step after that,
things don't necessarily go in a linear way,
a leadership coming to power that does want
to reintegrate Russia a bit with Europe, wants
to get out from under sanctions.
Indeed, I think it's a question of when, not
if, such a Russian leader comes out and one
of the things we ought to do is say and do
things that make that more likely.
We ought to talk about our future vision of
Russia's relationship with the West and the
United States.
We ought to talk about a relationship between
Ukraine and Russia that we believe, at least,
takes into account certain Russian concerns.
We ought to talk about our support for the
integrity of Russian territory.
We ought to respect Russia's right to choose
its own leadership.
Again, what matters to us is not who leads
Russia, but how those individuals act, what
kind of policies they pursue.
We want to deter Russian escalation, but we
also want to reassure Russia that our goals
are limited and our policies are conditioned
upon Russian behavior.
We do not want a Putin or anyone like him
to basically say, "We have no choice or we
have nothing to lose by acting recklessly
because there's nothing in it for us if we
act differently."
We always want them to understand that there
is something in it for them if they were to
act responsibly.
SIERRA: Do you think that it's just really
hard for people to understand these types
of situations, to fully comprehend what has
to be given and taken?
HAASS: I once had a conversation with the
president that I was working for in the government
and I outlined something that was at least
as complicated as this and he gave me a withering
look.
I said, "I know, I know.
There's a lot of nuance there."
But I said, "I work for the Department of
Nuance," since I worked for the Department
of State at the time.
He did not find that a winning argument.
But it's complicated.
It's going to be complicated to design.
Even more, it's going to be complicated to
sell, to sell it domestically here, to sell
it to the Russians, to sell it to Europe,
to sell it to Ukraine.
This is going to be extraordinarily difficult
to orchestrate.
And it may not be possible, but it's certainly
worth trying.
Look, diplomacy is an instrument of national
security.
We've got to do it.
I think we've got to think, consult.
Ultimately, we'd have to explain it and not
everyone's going to agree.
Okay. that's always the way it is.
But I take your point, and there might be
a lot of grays and people may not be in the
mood for grays.
They might want a lot of black and whites.
There'll be a lot of people, particularly
in Ukraine, understandably a hundred percent,
who have zero disposition to forgive and forget,
to compromise, to let people off the hook
on war crimes, on reparations, on sanctions,
on this on that, on accepting any limits on
what Ukraine can do on its territory.
That's something we're going to have to take
into account.
Could there be some differences of opinion
between the United States and Ukraine?
Absolutely.
That could happen.
We've had differences of opinion between the
United States and close allies before, we
have it all the time.
Being a close ally doesn't mean you have identity
of views.
It means you have a commitment to a larger
relationship and to larger purposes despite
the absence of identity of views.
We could have that with Ukraine, we could
have that with Europe.
That's okay.
That's why God invented diplomats.
SIERRA: Not nearly as satisfying though as
a...
HAASS: No, but Russia's a sovereign country.
It doesn't have a terribly capable conventional
military, but it does have a meaningful nuclear
arsenal, has significant energy resources.
It's an important country in the center of
Europe and Asia.
So it is in our long-term interest that Russia
is reintegrated in the world on terms that
we can mutually live with.
And that's going to be a very difficult conversation
with ourselves, with Ukraine, with others
because Russia under Putin has caused and
will continue to cause enormous damage to
people, to property, to principles.
But we may need to have that conversation
one day.
We're not there yet, but indeed, we're very
likely to have to have that conversation one
day.
It'll be difficult in the consultations in
private, it'll be extraordinarily difficult
in public in terms of explaining what will
look to some people as a compromise or even
an abdication of principle.
All you can do in those situations, I believe,
is get out there and explain why you believe,
however flawed or imperfect this proposal
is, it is less imperfect than the alternatives
that would come to pass if you didn't go down
that path.
That is the best you can do.
It's not satisfying.
SIERRA: It is not satisfying.
HAASS: I hear you.
I hear you.
That said, I look forward to the day we are
there because that would be considerably preferable
to where we are and are likely to be for some
time.
SIERRA: Well, I have one sort of last big
picture question for you and a comment which
is, talking about the world makes my friends
very unhappy.
They feel very bleak about the outlook of
the world.
HAASS: Is this where I tell you, you need
new friends?
SIERRA: Yes, exactly.
So short of getting new friends, I mean, are
we always going to live in a world where there's
a war, there's a war going on?
Is this just the way that it's going to be
forever?
HAASS: So much I could say, a couple things.
One is, if you look at the last 75 years since
World War II, one of the remarkable things
of this era is there was not a war between
the major powers of the day.
Yes, there were wars in Vietnam, Iraq, I understand,
but there was not a war between the United
States and the Soviet Union or the United
States and China.
After the Chinese Civil War, France and Germany
and Britain integrated in the European Union.
I mean, look at the contrast between the first
half of the 20th century on the second half
of the 20th century, night and day.
Also, during the last 70, 75 years, you can
tell your friends, that there was remarkable
progress.
A lot of the world became democratic.
The colonial period came to an end, not always
peacefully, but it came to an end.
The average lifespan increased by decades
around the world.
Tremendous scientific progress in medicine,
health across the...
Living standards multiplied by orders of magnitude.
So there was enormous progress.
So I don't believe that history is simply
bad or negative.
In some ways, it goes back to my favorite
book in the field, this book by an Australian
called Hedley Bull, The Anarchical Society.
At any moment in history, you have forces
of anarchy the things that tear us apart,
centrifugal forces, conflict, and you have
forces of society, things that bring us together.
One of the phrase we always hear is international
community.
Well, things that do make a little bit more
of a society or community around the world
where we team up to deal with aggression or
we team up to deal with disease or to regulate
the internet or whatever the particular causes,
or to stop the spread of nuclear weapons.
At any moment in history, there's always a
balance between these two.
To me, one way to think about foreign policy
is how do you shift the balance away from
anarchy somewhat in the direction of more
society.
It's really turning a dial.
It's not a switch.
You're never going to get all good stuff.
God willing, you'll never get all bad stuff.
What you want to do is change the balances,
you want to shift things slightly in a good
direction.
And I think for a big chunk of the last 75
years, we did just that.
I don't think we've done just that over the
last 10 or 15 years.
I think the dial's moving in the wrong direction.
And suddenly here, this conversation we've
had, it's actually one of those hinge moments.
And I believe a lot of lessons are going to
be learned about whether aggression pays,
whether might makes right.
Whether the West is a concept that actually
has meaning, whether alliances still work
and so forth.
This is one of those moments, tell your friends,
that if we get this right, it could yield
significant benefits.
It's not peace for the rest of time, but it
could move things in a better direction.
If we get this wrong, bad situations could
become worse.
What Russia would do elsewhere in Ukraine
or Europe, what the Chinese might do, based
upon this, against Taiwan, what North Korea
might do, what an Iran might do.
So this is one of those moments where there's
a lot of lessons being learned.
What we want to make sure is that the right
lessons are learned.
And if that's the case, then I believe as
awful as this has been, this act of aggression,
some good will come of it.
SIERRA: You heard it here, folks.
Richard Haass, optimist.
It's happening.
This has been great.
Thanks for chatting.
HAASS: Thanks for having me back.
SIERRA: Of course, anytime.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
If you have the time and love the show you
could leave us a review - it helps us get
noticed, and we love to read them.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our intern this semester is Mormei Zanke.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Claire Klobucista.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Jeff Reinke and
our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you around!